[Musique]
merci Corina rassigard nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu de la scène sa membre du groupe
socialiste on va revenir évidemment dans
quelques instants sur la crise des
agriculteurs mais d'abord l'autre
actualité c'est cette loi immigration
vous étiez membre vous de la commission
mixte paritaire et une grande partie de
la loi a donc été censurée hier par le
Conseil constitutionnel avant de revenir
en détail sur la décision comment vous
avez réagi à cette décision du Conseil
constitutionnel est-ce que vous attendz
à ce qu'autant d'articles soit censurés
35 sur les 86 oui c'est une satisfaction
c'est-à-dire que c'est s'il y a eu
autant d'articles censurés c'est quand
même parce que ce sont les
parlementaires de gauche qui ont saisi
le Conseil constitutionnel sur autant
d'articles il faut quand même bien le
dire et c'est justement parce que nous
avons bien vu que il y avait une très
large partie de cette loi qui n'était
pas constitutionnelle et la réalité
c'est que tout le monde le savait quand
on a voté la loi quand on a discuté en
CMP même avant quand on a déjà voté en
hémicycle a Sénat avant la CMP à droite
il savait très bien ce qu'il faisait et
le gouvernement aussi avait souvent
pointé du doigt toute ces
inconstitutionnalités tout en donnant
des avis de sagesse donc tout le monde
savait exactement ce qui était n'était
pas constitutionnel dans cette loi donc
il y a eu quoi un jeu de DUP comment
vous expliquer que oui il y a une grande
un grand jeu de manipulation politique
bien sûr et et et le dommage collatéral
très grave ce sont nos institutions et
le fonctionnement parlementaire voilà on
va revenir là-dessus en détail et sur
cette décision puisqu'on va voir quelles
ont été les mesures précisément qui ont
été retoqué Quentin calm vient nous
donner les détails de cette décision du
Conseil
[Musique]
constitutionnel bonjour Quentin bonjour
Aran char de vous retrouver mais de même
merci Quentin bonjour corineigin bonjour
le Conseil constitutionnel on le disait
a donc prononcé une censure importante
pas moins de 40 % de la loi immigration
a été supprimée de facto du texte
effectivement r on le voyait dans le
dans le reportage le sujet de Mathias
Arz juste avant la décision est tombée à
16h30 c'est la deuxème plus longue
jamais prononcé par la rue de montpenser
par les sages de la rue de montpensciier
et sur les 86 articles de la loi
immigration ce sont donc 32 qui ont été
retoqués pour des problèmes de forme le
Constitutionnel le juge constitutionnel
estime que ces mesures sont des
cavaliers législatifs c'est-à-dire que
le leur objet s'éloigne trop du texte
initial pour être accepté
plus grave encore vous le voyez juste en
dessous trois articles sont censurés sur
le fond ils sont contraires à la
Constitution enfin deux articles font
l'objet d'une réserve d'interprétation
de la part du Conseil constitutionnel
alors les 32 articles sens sur au motif
qu'ils sont des cavaliers législatifs ce
sont les ajouts de la droite et du
centre du Sénat voilà le Conseil estime
que ces articles n'ont pas de lien
direct avec la loi parmi les 32 mesures
il y a le durcissement de l'accès aux
prestations sociales la majorité de la
droite et du centre au Sénat qui voulait
conditionner ses allocations à une
certaine durée de présence sur le
territoire français 5 ans en
l'occurrence contre 6 mois actuellement
les juges ont écarté cet article car
trop éloigné du texte initial selon eux
autre mesure le durcissement du
regroupement familial avec une condition
de séjour qui passait à 24 mois au lieu
de 18 actuellement même chose encore
pour le délit de séjour illégal enfin la
caution retour pour les étudiants
étrangers a également été censuré oral
et vous le disiez Quentin il y a des
mesures qui ont été retoquées car
contraire à la Constitution voilà selon
les juges constitutionnels ce n'est pas
du ressort de la loi d'imposer au débat
un débat annuel au Parlement afin de
fixer des quotas migratoires les mesures
sur l'identification des clandestins
sans leur consentement sont jugés
attentatoires aux libertés individuelles
également les juges écartent les
changements dans la procédure de
l'examen d'octroi d'un titre de séjour
c'est une censure partiale sur ce
dernier point enfin à signaler c'est
très important la régularité tion dans
les métiers entention au cas par cas par
les préfets a été validé hein c'est un
des articles dont on parlait le plus
depuis le début de l'examen de ce texte
d'ailleurs les préfets sont convoqués ce
matin pour recevoir les premières
instructions géralde Darmanin a assuré
disposer de l'intégralité des moyens
dont il a besoin pour lutter contre la
délinquence étrangère Corine narigin on
voit toutes ces mesures censurées sur le
fond sur la forme on est d'accord que
c'est un revers pour la droite
parlementaire vous le pensez oui sur je
pense qu'il y a certaines mesures dont
ils espérait qu'elle ne soit pas
considéré comme des cavaliers
législatifs notamment sur le
regroupement familial je crois mais la
réalité c'est qu'ils ont quand même leur
victoire politique euh parce que parce
que les Tex pour vous c'est une victoire
de la droite cette censure du Conseil
constitionnel non pas la censure mais le
fait que le texte est quand même été
voté il savait très bien qu'une grande
partie je l' dis il savait très bien
qu'une grande partie ce texte allait
probablement censuré et en réalité il le
cherchait aussi peut-être pas autant de
censure mais en tout cas il cherchait ça
parce que on voit bien le discours été
préparé et là encore on voit c'est le
même discours à droite et à l'extrême
droite malheureusement c'est très
inquiétant c'est pour dire bien quand
même ces mesures ont été voté y compris
par la majorité présidentielle he et
donc maintenant elles doivent être
revoté dans un nouveau texte de loi euh
puisque c'était ce que voulait le
Parlement et puis ça prouve bien qu'il
faut changer la constitution la
Constitution est mauvaise voilà donc en
fait au final ça va dans le sens de leur
récit du récit politique qui cherche à
installer depuis déjà pluss Gérald
armant dit c'est le texte initial du
gouvernement qui
viireal c'est c'est faux puisque
lui-même reconnaît c'est un texte à
l'origine avec 27 articles maintenant il
va en faire passer 50 par ailleurs
c'était censé être un texte équilibré
c'est-à-dire un texte qui améliore
l'intégration des étrangers en situation
régulière sur notre territoire il ne
reste plus rien de cette partie-là et
c'était un texte qui était censé euh
dans le contrôle de l'immigration
illégal être méchant avec les méchants
là c'est juste plus de désordes dans sur
les la question de de de la la r il va
il va prétendre que c'est plus de
sécurité en réalité ça va créer plus de
confusion et plus de désordre sur les
obligations de quité territoire la
multiplication des obligations de quité
territoire qu'on ne saura toujours pas
mieux exécutter et puis euh et puis aura
moins de recours possible euh oui parce
que simplement on s'est déjà pas exécuté
euh on en exécute que 10 à 12 %
aujourd'hui donc les multipliés ça ne
résoudra pas le problème initial on sait
pas comment les gérer et et souvent
elles sont mal prononcées voilà et en
plus là on assouplit euh les euh les
critères pour les prononcer donc
vraiment je vois pas en quoi ça va nous
sécuriser euh et puis euh et puis le la
mesure de de régularisation euh des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension euh bah ça ça va pas
être un droit euh fort ça va en en gros
on va on va avoir euh euh la même chose
que ce qu'on a déjà c'estàd une
régularisation au cas par cas par les
préfets ce qui existe déjà avec la
circulaire Vals et en plus ça va être
restreint à euh des métiers en tension
qui sont définis dans un décret dont
tout le monde sait que ce ce décret ne
correspond pas à la réalité des métiers
en tenstion il ne peut pas correspondre
à la réalité des métiers en tenstion
puisque bah le travail dissimulé par
définition et ben il se déclare pas et
donc ça ne se voit pas à vous entendre
on se dit tout ça pour ça toute cette
séquence ça fait 2 ans qu'on parle de ce
de ce projet de loi immigration un an et
demi j'exagère un peu mais on se dit
finalement on a vraiment eu des débats
intenses pour pas grand-chose à la fin
bah pour au fin à la fin quand même un
un débat qui a installé le fait que une
forme de de racisme et de xénophobie
généralisée dans le traitement de
l'immigration que l'assimilation
systématique à l'étranger comme un
délinquant potentiel ben c'est normal ça
c'est quand même extrêmement grave
politiquement pour le pays et puis et
puis là on va avoir quand même une
mauvaise loi qui va être promulguée
c'est pour ça que nous nous demandons
nous continuons à demander qu'elle soit
retirée parce que c'est une loi une loi
essentiellement de de police des
étrangers et qui en plus pr dans les
praines HE a bien compris mais voilà je
je pense que Contin qu même demander oui
par que ça parce que voilà parce que
toute la procédure a été faussée on voit
bien la manière dont ça a été adopté
cette loi vous l'avez dit vous-même au
début c'était c'était un jeu DUP qui je
suis d'accord avec cette expression là
qu'ils ont essayé d'installer parce que
au final ils voulaient absolument voter
cette
loi et et et c'est la loi effectivement
que finalement geréralmanin voulait qui
était une loi d'agitation avec laquelle
il va pouvoir faire de l'agitation
sécuritaire mais ça n'est pas du tout
une bonne loi pour le
pays un mot Quentin ouais oui euh un mot
sur ce que dit la droite euh vous disiez
ils avaient anticipé cette censure
partiale nous on était dans le bureau de
Bruno rotillo hier il avait l'air assez
contrarié par ce qui s'est passé la
droite qui critique la décision du
Conseil constite et du Conseil
constitutionnel les juges ser allés trop
loin dans leur appréciation de ce qui
relève ou pas de ces fameux cavaliers
euh lui voilà BR r il dit tous les
sujets qu'on a qu'on a posé ce sont bien
des sujets en lien avec l'immigration
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a'urait pas le
droit de légiférer qu'est-ce que vous
vous en pensez mais je pense que c'est
assez normal que il y ait cette ce ce
cet article de de dans la Constitution
qui soit respecté par le législateur
justement parce qu'on peut pas utiliser
n'importe quel véhicule législatif pour
intégrer ses lubi parce que c'est
vaguement connexe ou c'est un peu là
c'est un texte sur l'immigration oui
mais c'est un texte qui qui visait à
contrôler l'immigration illégale et à
mieux intégrer je ne vois pas en quoi
rendre plus difficile le regroupement
familial aide à mieux intégrer les
Français les les les étrangers qui sont
sur le sol français déjà en situation
régulière et et donc et donc c'est c'est
à ce titre là ça vis à mieux contrôler
l'immigration pour les républicains ce
qui était aussi la partie du Tex avait
deux parties avait partie contrôle
parement il ils estiment que une bonne
immigration c'est une immigration qui
n'existe pas voilà donc c'est pour ça
que c'est pour eux c'est c'est le
contrôle ça veut dire laisser les gens
dehors mais ça c'est pas contrôer
l'immigration enfin
vraiment le regroupement familial en
plus c'est un c'est un droit européen
c'est un droit international qu'on est
qu'on doit respecter et donc d'ailleurs
je je suis certaine qu'il y aura des
associations qui ensuite vont pouvoir
poser des questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité sur certains autres
articles quand les décrets sont sortis
et qui pourront faire appel probablement
à au au à des à des remises en cause sur
des conventions des conventions
européennes et internationales au final
Quentin le rappel il y a très peu de
mesures qui ont été censurées sur le
fond il y a seulement trois articles qui
ont été censurés sur le fond est-ce que
ça vous le regretter alors oui parce que
il y a je je pense qu'il y a des
notamment sur la question de de
l'article préférence nationale c'estàd
celle qui restreint les les les les
aides les aides de sociales les
allocations familiales notamment les
aides de logement au aux étrangers en
situation régulière euh délai oui pardon
mais là le Conseil constitutionnel a pas
dit c'est contraire à la Constitution il
a just dit ça a rien à faire dans ce
sont arrêtés parce qu'ils ont ils sont
arrêtés au premier filtre le premier
filre c'est normal que ce soit l'article
45 donc la question du cavalier
législatif ils auraient comment ils ont
aussi été saisi sur le fond ils auraient
aussi pu choisir de se prononcer sur le
fond ils n'ont pas choisi de le faire et
donc ça va maintenant permettre à la
droite de poser un nouveau une nouvelle
demande de loi sur cette question
exactement c'est c'était ma dernière
question les aler qui demande au
gouvernement de présenter un nouveau
projet de loi avec les mesures retoquées
pour cause de cavalier quand les
centristes eux ont même déjà dit qu'ils
allaient faire une proposition de loi
donc une initiative parlementaire pour
eux-mêmes s'emparer de de ce débat
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à la droite
et au centre au Sénat moi je pourquoi
pas avoir ce débat finalement je suis
pas étonné on l'a déjà eu nous on a déjà
dit notre position sur le fond sur ces
questionsl euh et et donc la question
c'est est-ce que maintenant benah les
les les macronistes vont montrer leur
vrai visage qui était que il ils ont
joué avec les institution en votant des
des choses dont ils savaient très bien
que ça allait être censuré par le
Conseil constitutionnel et maintenant
ils vont nous expliquer qu'en fait ils
avvaient maintenant ils vont être contre
ce pourquoi ils avaient voté en décembre
donc tout çaà tout ça c'est une grosse
mascarade je je je je c'est assez
concernant vraiment et c'est pas ça qui
va conforter rétablir le lien de
confiance entre les Français et les élus
sauf qu'on on a vous l'avez vu hein dans
les sondages qui sont publiés depuis des
semaines les Français étaient
majoritairement favorables à cette loi
il demande un meilleur contrôle de
l'immigration est-ce que ce qui s'est
passé hier finalement ne va pas faire le
jeu du rassemblement national je sais
pas à quel point les Français étai
euh au courant du détail de ce qu' y
avait dans la loi et de la manière dont
les choses allaient s'appliquer de quels
sont les les la la la la réalité de de
la qui serait la réalité de dans leur
majorité ils disent il faut des mesures
pour mieux contrôler l'immigration
compris les sympathisants de gauche mais
bien sûr mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez
quand vous faites un sondage vous
demandez aux gens est-ce que vous pensez
que il faut avoir la plus de capacité de
contrôler de d'expulser les les les les
étrangers dangereux qui va vous répondre
une question rétorique selon vous oui
voilà enfin mais par contre ils étaient
aussi très pour que on on régularise
qu'on facilite la régularisation de ceux
qui travaillent ceux qui déjà souvent
payent des impôts et cotisent en fait à
not système
social et ça ça ne sera pas vraiment
facilité dans ce dans ce texte de loi
merci Quentin tout à l'heure mercian oui
je reviens dans le club on parlera
encore de ce projet de l' migration on
verra les réactions politiques depuis
hier on verra ça avec vous tout à
l'heure dans quelques instants Quentin
on va parler de l'autre actualité c'est
évidemment cette crise des agriculteurs
qui se poursuit les blocages qui se
poursuivent on attend des réponses de
Gabriel hatal le Premier ministre
aujourd'hui mais d'abord on va voir
comment ça se passe du côté du centre on
va à limoge on rejoint Olivier
chappreron bonjour Olivier merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous rédacteur en
chef du populaire du centre et
évidemment cette agricoles et ces
blocages occupent encore aujourd'hui une
large place dans vos colonnes Olivier
oui bonjour ah effectivement oui c'est
l'actualité du jour alors en Limousin
partout en France au-delà de la loi
immigration euh parce que le mouvement
s'amplifie hein il était déjà monté très
rapidement aujourd'hui on constate que
dans le Limousin la corise est rentrée
dans le jeu ce qui était le dernier
département du secteur à ne pas avoir
encore de fortes mobilisation
l'autoroute av le le Paris Toulouse est
bloqué en corè bloqué en Haut- de
viienne euh la nationale est bloqué
aussi en Creuse le mouvement
s'intensifie puisque d'autres syndicats
ont ont regagné le mouvement lancé par
la FNSEA euh il faut dire que les
représentants sont très nombreux ici
alors tout se passe plutôt bien c'est
très organisé les autoroutes sont
bloquées les déviations sont mises al ça
cré la pagaille évidemment dans les
centre-villes dans les Bours qui sont
traversés par les poids lourds euh c'est
un peu plus dangereux pour la
circulation routière quotidienne mais on
sent ils sont très déterminés les
agriculteurs ils ont pas du tout envie
de baisser les bras et les réponses
doivent être à la hauteur de ce qu'ils
attendent sinon je pense que ça va durer
encore un petit moment euh sur les
autoroutes il va falloir quand même que
euh les opérations de dégagement soient
faites une fois qu'ils auront quitté les
lieux mais euh c'est pas encore à
l'actualité parce que je pense qu'ils
attendent énormément de ce que Gabriel
Atal pourrait annoncer alors on dit
qu'il pourrait l'annoncer en haut Garon
là où ils se déplac aujourd'hui euh mais
ils sont tous convaincus que euh ce sera
pas des mesurettes qui qui les font qui
les feront bouger puisque euh ben ici
comme ailleurs les les revenus des
agriculteurs sont en baisse les les
lourdeur AD adistratif s'accumule donc
c'est vrai que c'est c'est très c'est
très très compliqué et on sent qu'il y a
une même si ça se passe dans la bonne
humeur même si effectivement on voit les
barbecue fleurir et et c'est plutôt
sympathique ils sont très déterminés
c'est certain ouais quel est juste un
mot Olivier de la particularité de de
l'agriculture
local alors ici on est pas dans deses
dans des plines céréalières ouin s'en
faut puisque c'est essentiellement de
l'élevage alors l'élevage bovvin avec la
limousine qui est une race reconnue qui
permettait jusqu'alors aux agriculteurs
d'avoir plutôt des revenus assez
confortables surtout pour ceux qui
faisaient et pour la plupart le fond la
qualité hein de la grande qualité la
viande est très reconnue euh pour autant
bah leur marche descendent et puis et
puis ils sont confrontés à une
accumulation de norm à une accumulation
de de de contrôle on a eu encore un
exemple il y a quelques jours où un
agriculteur a failli voir son chaptel
totalement abattre euh parce qu'il y
avait une une un soupçon de de maladie
contagieuse il a fallu quatre tests pour
se rendre compte que finalement ces test
était justement négatif et à une journée
près le chtel était totalement abattu
donc le préfet est venu en personne
s'excuser auprès de l'exploitant c'est
vous dire si la tension était déjà
grande oui il y a une particularité
locale ici c'est que les exploitants ne
vivent plus correctement de le de leur
travail et je ne vous parler même pas de
ceux qui sont dans le nord de de du
Limousin qui qui élèv des des moutons
notamment et qui eux sont très très
enificulté mais c'est vrai aussi des des
pomiculteurs on en a quelquesuns enfin
on en a même beaucoup ici et qui
arrivent qui difficilement à tirer leur
épingle du jeu ouis Olivier vous avez
une question pour Corina rassigin alors
oui on sent bien que il y a des demandes
et la liste est très très longue des
revendications va quand même faire
falloir à un moment ou un autre que le
gouvernement se tourne vers l'Europe
alors comment aujourd'hui un
gouvernement français va pouvoir aller à
la Commission européenne et demander des
des des exemptions des particularités
locales des dérogations comment ça peut
se négocier parce que on voit mal
décider unilatéralement de Paris des
solutions qui ont un impact direct sur
sur sur l'urope alors je crois que il y
a un sujet qui est plus profond qui est
plus large que ça bien sûr il va y avoir
des mesures je veux dire d'urgence
peut-être à prendre mais au niveau
européen et puis là on va s'engager dans
une campagne avec des élections euh je
crois qu'il va y avoir un un sujet
beaucoup plus profond que ça parce que
la révolte des agriculteurs en France
elle avait déjà commencé dans d'autres
pays en Europe donc on voit bien qu'il y
a un problème général en Europe sur la
rémunération des agriculteurs le fait
que effectivement on a beaucoup qui
vivent pas de leur revenus c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que les socialistes ont
demandé qu' commission d'enquête qui
soit ouverte par le Sénat sur le revenu
agricole par qu'il a en plus de grandes
variations on sait selon évidemment les
territoires et les secteurs agricole et
les tailles des exploitations et cetera
donc il y a effectivement des marches de
plus en plus faibles pour les
agriculteur alors qu'il y a une
industrie
agroalimentaire et et des des
distributeurs qui eux voient leur marge
augmenter et au final le consommateur
lui voit aussi ses prix augmentés donc
ni le consommateur ni l'agriculteur ne
gagne dans cette chaîne donc il y a un
énorme problè problème par rapport à ça
et il y a un problème de modèle
globalement la question c'est pas c'est
évidemment comment est-ce queon applique
les normes de manière plus intelligente
mais c'est aussi au niveau européen
comment on s'oppose à des à des à des
accords de libre échange comme le
mercosour parce que c'est aussi ça le
problème c'est la concurrence desloyales
au qu'ell font face les agriculteurs
français mais aussi plus généralement
européens par rapport à des agriculteurs
dans d'autres parties du monde qui ne
sont pas soumis à ces normesl et ces
normesl euh il y en a peut-être que
certaines ont besoin d'être u dans le
dans leur efficacité mais on a besoin
aussi de transformer notre agriculture
parce que on a besoin de prendre en
compte non seulement la sécurité
alimentaire la santé la santé des des
des consommateurs mais aussi la des
questions de transition écologique et
les agriculteurs sont les premers les
premiers à souffrir des dérèglements
climatiques donc il y a un modèle à
repenser il s'adapte il s'adapte à à à
l'écologie mais est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on
ne fait pas peser sur eux trop de
contraintte Environnmental c'est là où
il faut évaluer la France par exemple
quand on a voté la la PAC 2023 n'a pas
joué son rôle pour justement repenser la
PAC pour qu'il y ait bien meilleur
accompagnement des agriculteurs dans
cette transation de plus en plus de
normes écologiqu et de contraintte
environnemental est-ce que il y a pas
trop de pression des écologistes sur les
agriculurs il y a un problème
d'accompagnement parce qu'on on pose des
normes mais on leur donne pas les moyens
de les appliquer donc la question c'est
l'accompagnement y compris financier
pour pouvoir les accompagner dans ces
transition là c'est ça le sujet
aujourd'hui c'est c'est aussi et puis
aussi de de s'assurer que les
subventions elles vont pas justement
uniquement d'abord au gant céréaliers
d'abord voilà que que que ça soit aussi
équitable et et aussi il y a un autre
sujet mais ça c'est un sujet plus
français sur la la la question de du
foncier et du fait que on a un problème
aussi d'accaparement des terres et et et
d'installation de transmission c'est
qu'il il y a une grande partie de nos
agriculteurs qui vont partir à la
retraite dans 10 ans on a un problème
aussi de renouvellement de générations
et et de et de peut-être de
multiplication des plus des plus petites
euh euh euh exploitation à taille
humaine et d'où une loi qui est qui
aurait dû être présentée d'ailleurs
cette semaine en conseil des ministres
qui a été reporté une loi de
renouvellement de génération des
agriculteurs qu'est-ce que vous attendez
de cette loi bah justement on attend que
il y ait de de vraies mesures qui soient
prises sur la question du foncier et sur
la question de la transmission euh des
exploitations ouz euh il y a des
syndicats euh vous avez vu les blocages
se poursuivent et des syndicats qui
appellent aujourd'hui au blocus de Paris
euh le mouvement se rapproche de
l'île-de-fance est-ce que vous soutenez
la manière dont les agriculteurs
manifestent aujourd'hui alors moi je
suis je je pense que le droit de
manifester un droit qui doit absolument
être protégé qu'ils ont de vraies
revendications et que ils ont tout à
fait le droit de venir sur Paris pour se
faire entendre du gouvernement par
contre les violences les Aes de barbarie
animal ça ça n'est pas ça n'est pas
acceptable quand vous entendez Gérald
armanin hier au 20H dire qu'il n'enverra
pas les forces de l'ordre contre les
agriculteurs ils ne s'en prennent pas au
policiers il ne s'en prennent pas au
gendarmes ils ne s'en prnent pas au bien
public c'est ce que dit le ministre de
l'Intérieur est-ce que vous comprenez la
stratégie du gouvernement j'ai j'ai
quand même vu qu'ils s'en sont pris à
des biens publics à des préfecture voilà
et donc ça ça n'est pas acceptable ça
n'est jamais acceptable quel que soit
les manifestants mais vous comprenez que
Géral d'Anin disent on n'en verra pas
les forces de
l'ordre je je comprends pas très bien la
différence de traitement c'est ça mon
sujet c'est pourquoi est-ce que on
envoie des forces de l'ordre quand c'est
des
manifestations d'enseignant de chemineau
ou
euh de de d'écologistes sur certains
sites voilà où a priori on considère
queil fautavoir quasiment plus de
policiers que de
manifestants et donc là a quoi il y a
deux poids de mesure oui oui alors enfin
moi
je qui disent qui qui disent on va pas
traiter on va pas répondre à la misère
en envoyant les forces de l'ordre c'est
plutôt un bon réflexe c'est dommage que
ce soit uniquement quand ça concerne les
agriculteurs mais pourquoi il y a trop
de de laisser faire de la part du
gouvernement faire ses agriculteurs bon
il y a une complaisance électorale on va
dire peut-être enfin je je pense ici je
ne sais pas si c'est la enfin c'est
peut-être pas la la réalité peut-être de
moins en moins la réalité aujourd'hui en
terme électoral mais en tout cas ils
estiment que c'est beaucoup plus leur
électorat que que que d'autres d'autres
groupes de manifestants peut-être
Olivier une autre question regarde votre
une on peut regarder la une
effectivement oui allez on regarde la
une la mobilisation ne faiblit pas c'est
à la du populaire du centre aujourd'hui
évidemment et et plusieurs pages qui
sont consacrés à cette colère agricole
et on attend on disait les réponses de
Gabrielle à tal ce sera dans
l'après-midi du côté de la Haute Garonne
merci beaucoup Olivier chaperon merci
d'avoir été avec nous et et à très vite
évidemment dans cette émission un mot
sur un autre sujet Corine narassigin
c'est la question de l'IVG de la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG puisque
l'Assemblée nationale l'a voté cette
semaine ça va maintenant arriver au
Sénat et Gérard Larchet s'est exprimé
là-dessus cette semaine il a dit qu'il
n'était pas favorable à l'inscription de
l'IVG dans la Constitution ça veut dire
pour vous ça ne passera pas au Sénat on
verra je pense qu'il va falloir compter
les votes il va y avoir un travail à
faire notamment évidemment les groupes
de gauche c'est déjà acquis mais au
niveau de des groupes centristes et
d'une partie des républicains je
regrette que le le le président de la
Haute Assemblée s'exprime de cette
manière qui ce qui je crois une position
personnelle qui n'est pas non plus a
priori la position officielle de son
groupe en tout cas collective unanime de
son groupe hier soir a dit qu'il était
d'accord avec Gérard l le président du
groupe oui mais je comprends aussi que
au sein du groupe tout le monde n'est
pas sur cette ligne euh donc et donc
quand le le président du Sénat s'exprime
de cette manière pour exprimer son
opinion personnelle effectivement ça
jette le trouble et c'est dommageable
alors que le texte n'est même pas encore
arrivé en commission au Sénat euh et
vous pensez qu'il passera ou pas parce
que la dernière fois il est passé mais
c'était pas exactement les mêmes termes
c'est la liberté qui a été votée par le
Sénat là le gouvernement a fait passé un
texte qui dit liberté garantie ce qui
pose des problèmes chez certains
républicains qui avaient voté pour la
dernière fois oui alors le le le texte
qui avait voté par par été voté par le
Sénat à l'origine en réalité n'aurait
pas été particulièrement utile en terme
de changement constitutionnel et donc
c'est le le texte qui est proposé
aujourd'hui est un meilleur texte et je
évidemment nous souhaitons qu'il soit
qu'il soit qu'il soit voté mais je je ne
sais pas encore parce que je pense que
effectivement on voit bien qu'il y a un
revers très conservatiste
recul chez en terme de voilà sur sur ces
sujets de de société qui
réaffirme il y a un espèce de retour en
arrière on avait cru qu'il y avait eu du
progrès à droite mais on a un espèce de
retour en arrière donc je pense qu'il va
falloir compter les votes je ne sais pas
du tout si ça passera et vous vous
reviendrez pas sur liberté garantie pour
vous ça sera soit ça soit rien non parce
que sinon si on enlève le garanti en
réalité ça c'est c'est un changement
cosmétique mais qui ne ne justement ne
garantira pas véritablement le droit à
l'IVG dans la Constitution merci Corina
rassig merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité pendant cette première demiheure